US President Donald Trump has held his
first-ever summit with his Russian
counterpart Vladimir Putin at talks in
the Finnish capital Helsinki the para
promised to improve relations between
their two countries despite a number of
troublesome issues well that includes
allegations that Russia meddled in the
2016 US election although Putin denied
any Russian interference the pair also
discussed nuclear stocks Syria and the
Mideast at large as they sought to
reboot relations between Washington and
Moscow all right let's see if they
managed to do that let's go straight to
House sinky our correspondent teri
Shultz is on the scene
teri hi Leila well it remains to be seen
when as president Trump said the
national security council's will work
out what actually was agreed here what
we heard from the press conference was
both presidents sounding very
conciliatory toward each other
President Putin denying that Russia ever
has or ever will meddle in u.s.
elections and president Trump's seeming
to take him at his word he said I don't
see why Russia would have meddled in our
elections and then went off on a long
spiel about it being the DNC and Hillary
and Hillary staffers that being Hillary
Clinton of course his opponent in the
u.s. presidential elections some of the
other issues that people would have
liked to hear more about would have been
president Trump reiterating US policy
NATO policy European policy that Crimea
was illegally annexed by Moscow
President Trump did not say that and
President Putin used the old line that
you know Crimea held an election and
decided to be part of Russia so it now
belongs to the Russian Federation some
of the other things we didn't hear
anything about were for example this
[ __ ] poisoning the international
community has pointed a finger at Russia
for this poisoning that didn't even come
up of course journalists only got a
handful of questions to both the Russian
and the u.s. sides so President Trump
came out and said you know the
relationship has been bad but I think
we're going to turn a corner now there's
a bright future he blamed bad relations
on pre
administration's and said now it's time
to take a new step in this relationship
President Putin less effusive but no
less positive about the direction that
they both thought these sides should
should move in there were some other
things that just struck my ears for
example President Trump saying that the
US and Russian militaries cooperate very
well there are you know NATO patrols
that are scrambled every few days
because Russian warplanes are buzzed
NATO airspace and u.s. is part of those
patrols I wouldn't say that is getting
along very well I think what he must
have been referring to was in the
airspace over Syria there is a working
arrangement not a partnership meant by
any means but sort of a mutual
information line so that they can avoid
collisions of airspace in Syria and I
can only imagine that's the only thing
that he could have been referring to
with our militaries working together of
course it was the Russian military that
performs snap exercises on very near the
borders of the Baltic States it is the
Russian military that NATO is mobilized
to counter should it cross into NATO
territory so that was a bit surprising
but I think that a couple of the
statements that we'll will stick with
everybody as President Putin saying
we're going to move forward on the basis
of truth not rumors and a president
Trump going right along with that yes
they gave us a lot of the stuff to talk
about and will do so also with our
colleagues in Washington as well and in
Moscow but before I let you go Terry
when these two leaders meet there's a
lot of drama and build-up that this
meeting live up to the hype it certainly
did of course everyone outside these two
leaders was worried about the one-on-one
session and that's because of course
there are suspicions that President
Trump is too friendly to President Putin
and they're holding a meeting with only
interpreters would mean nobody knows
what said nobody knows what's promised
nobody knows if there are any
concessions made particularly on the US
side toward the Russian side something
like a promise that you know the u.s.
doesn't really need to participate in
NATO exercises that would protect the
Baltic States that was one big worry
also on what might happen in Syria they
were
very worried about you know what what
President Trump may want to walk away
with some kind of victory from the
Russian president and what might be up
for grabs for President Putin in that in
that situation so I think that that was
the biggest drama that meeting went on
longer than scheduled two hours with
just those two men in the room and we'll
we'll never know exactly what was said
and then of course the meeting with
advisors also longer than expected we
waited a long time on that picture of
waiting for the press conference and I
think that um they didn't disappoint I
think we expected them to come out both
declaring victory and I think that's
exactly what we heard all right and
Terry that is exactly what makes this so
very difficult is that there is no
official record of what's been said so
we just have to go by what these two
leaders have said teri Schultz reporting
live from Helsinki thank you